Another Hero you guys met I believe this  is a photo of of you uh JT with Arnold  Schwarzenegger how did you how did you  meet him by the way all your the  pictures of you guys with celebrities  are so good  because obviously have a really good  camera yeah  Arnold reached out to us and he wanted  to lift and we were like of course and  the thing about Arnold is is he's  perpetually inspiring everything he says  is inspiring everything about him is  contagious including his accent yeah  yeah yeah he's um he was telling us you  know during your deadlifts say I can do  it very inspiring and I couldn't help  but do the accent so in front of him I  was like I can do it  and uh and I pried yeah  [Applause]  you'd be hard that's exciting yeah